has the Republican Party lost its mind
and its way in its slavish Devotion to
Donald Trump who insists that the 2020
election was stolen from him through
extensive voter fraud that's the
question that journalist Robert Draper
investigates in his new book Weapons of
Mass delusion which looks at Rising
Republican Stars such as Georgia
representative Marjorie Taylor green and
failed Arizona gubernatorial candidate
Carrie Lake who are DieHard Trump
Loyalists and established Party leaders
such as likely Speaker of the House
Kevin McCarthy who is openly terrified
to cross the former president reason
spoke with Draper shortly after the
midterm elections in which the GOP had
an unexpectedly poor showing against a
massively unpopular Joe Biden is this a
sign that Trump's hold on his party and
the country is weakening and is there
any reason to believe that the party of
Ronald Reagan and Barry Goldwater May
return to its small government Roots
Draper also reflects on his 2014 New
York Times magazine cover story as the
libertarian moment finally arrived which
prominently featured reasons Nick
Gillespie and Matt Welch
[Music]
Robert Draper thanks for talking to
reason thanks for having me on Nick all
right well let's uh start with the
elevator pitch of weapons of mass
delusion when the Republican Party lost
its mind sure this is not a history book
it is a book about a snapshot in time
that I believe is of historical
significance
um and that is a roughly 16 to 18 month
period that began with January the 6th
um when I was inside the capitol that
day and that moment of Madness it would
have seemed to me would have would have
been the moment for the Republican party
to descend into a kind of humble
meditation take stock of their role in
the in their Insurrection and they are
upon Endeavor to purge the corrosive
elements uh in their party that led to
the Insurrection instead what they did
of course was something very different
they doubled down on it and um and the
Maga movement and the disinformation
that propelled it became the uh
gravitational Center basically of the
Republican party this book had me doing
a deep repertoryal dive into the
Republican Party during that period can
I uh do you have a politics are you a
Republican or a Democrat or an
independent registered independent and
I've been that way since I've been an
adult I'm I um and generally speaking my
my politics aren't terribly interesting
you know I'm not really an ideologue I'm
more anthropological I mean I vote you
know but um uh but I've voted for
Democrats and Republicans and
Libertarians with equal levels of
remorse and recrimination you know so
and ineffectiveness I assume at least
that's right
um so let me ask because or let's start
with you talk about
um you know and and the book is richly
reported uh you're obviously a uh you
know a stylist uh with you know without
parallel or with few peers uh writing
and long-form journalism today
um so um it's it's great to read on uh
you know just on that level but on uh I
think it's page 199 or 195 or
thereabouts you talk about three lies
um and within within weeks of the
Insurrection of the riot at the Capitol
Building you say the chain of Lies had
come to form a perfect circle the first
lie the big lie was that the election
was stolen the second lie was that the
steel could be unstolen on January 6
whether through legal or extra legal
means and the third and final lie was
that those who attempted to unsteel it
were in fact not Trump supporters and I
kind of want to walk through those real
quick and then I want to talk about some
of the characters because
um you know the I mean the subtitle of
your book is when the Republican Party
lost its mind we are dealing with a lack
of Engagement with you know with reality
on the part of this party or at least a
significant portion of it let's start
with the big lie that the election was
stolen and that starts even before the
2020 election right but it does how did
that come into being and that is mostly
Trump kind of promoting that front and
center it is with a buck that comes
after that but first to address the
Trump aspect of it I mean we're talking
about a guy who simply stated has been a
sore loser all his life and whenever he
has lost his son he's a sore winner as
well I mean yeah true yeah yeah there's
no there's no grace to the guy
um but whenever he has lost he's tended
to blame someone else the very first
political contest he was in you'll
recall Nick was the Iowa caucus of 2016.
he lost to Ted Cruz he claimed the crews
had rigged it he subsequently did that
with Wyoming and Colorado caucuses and
in the run-up to the 26th election said
you know if
um uh Hillary's going to try to rig it
against me even as you point out when he
did win he still said he would have won
New Hampshire but for the rigging that
supposedly took place so and and so that
that's that's been Trump's game for a
while but it played into two things and
it took me a while to appreciate
um these two other elements one was that
the this lie the notion that if the
Democrats win in 2020 it would only be
because they stole it play into a
long-standing view amongst Republicans
the Democrats steal they cheat all the
time and it's and you can talk to run a
mill Republicans throughout the decades
and this is what they've been told and
they accept it the way they casually
accept that Hillary Clinton is a crook
um and so calling her crooked Hillary
may not have been a polite company way
to say it but it just been widely
assumed absent however any indictment
much less a conviction that Clinton
um wasn't correct so that's one thing
that um Trump was tapping into whether
he was aware of it or not at the time
but the broader
um uh thing that that Trump tapped into
with his stolen election claims
was a sense of loss a sense of
forfeiture on the part of large swaths
of non-college educated white
working-class Americans who believed
that America as they knew it was being
stolen from them bit by bit and so that
their Champion
um had been that his victory had been
thwarted through
um ill-gotten gains uh fed
metaphorically and in all other
meaningful ways into this notion that um
that the rightful Owners of America were
having their America stolen from them so
those are you know the subtexts of
Trump's outrageous claims and I think
why it is the tens of millions of people
bought into these claims because I I was
uh in preparation for this I was looking
up it's still you know they're not
asking pollsters aren't asking this
question as much as they used to but
going back to earlier this year
something like 70 percent of Republicans
still say that Joe Biden was not fairly
elected and that could mean a lot of
things but it's also true that you know
it wasn't just Trump in the 2016
election I can recall both Hillary and
Trump saying you know what the system is
rigged the system isn't working the
system is rigged Bernie Sanders would
say that in a more particularly in 2016
it was more in a class thing that you
know uh the capitalists or or you know
the Fat Cats the one percent the system
is rigged against you you know the
normal working-class person Trump's
version of that is much more overblown
and more seems more targeted or was more
targeted towards this kind of sense of
dispossessed white people mostly men not
always uh and increasing I guess in 2020
less white than previously right I mean
so it's part I mean and I think that's
important and I you you kind of touch on
that in the book this sense of being
dispossessed by large over overarching
conspiracies is kind of not quite the
right word but systems that don't give a
[__] about you and you're done and you
know Trump Taps into that right that's
part of what he's speaking to that's
right I mean it of course it was ironic
that
um you know it always seemed a bit
dubious from the outset that this
billionaire real estate developer from
Manhattan could be the champion of the
working class but the way he sold
himself to people who lived in States
like South Carolina and Georgia that
Trump only knew from the golf courses
there was by I'm sharing the same
enemies with them you know that's that's
how uh I think he wedded their appetite
for him by by talking about how China
had screwed them over how um how the
government had basically given away the
store and these trade deals how the
Border was wide open and people were
taking these things from them and so uh
after a while they they loved um they
love that language that Trump was was
speaking they loved as well how he would
say it and take whatever slings and
arrows came his way and so I think those
were the two
um overlapping elements that that
um uh that made Trump the guy when it
seemed so unlikely that he would be that
individual yeah and um but then there
Comes This Moment On election night I
mean because part of it is you know
Trump in 2020
you know when the election when the the
polls shut down because of you know it's
late in the night he's kind of ahead the
popular vote or whatever but everybody
knows
there are tons of votes to be counted
because of early voting mail and voting
all of that kind of stuff and then I
mean Trump obviously obviously goes with
this but so do a lot of people who
should know better to say that you know
if Trump you know he's the winner on
Election night when not all the votes
have been counted because a lot of them
have been cast weeks ahead of time and
won't be candidate until weeks after but
if he's not declared the winner then
it's fraud
um right who you know who are the
progenitors of that kind of mindset and
um you know that seems to take over in a
big way too sure and I and I think that
hard hard to say who's the absolute
first who came up with that notion
um but we do know some people who acted
on that notion some people who are the
great amplifiers of of that notion and
um you know for example a right-wing
congressman from Arizona named Paul
gosar who uh had
um hosted the first stop the steel rally
which happened to be in Phoenix the day
after the election ghosts are like a lot
of Republicans was relying entirely on
experience and and Nick I feel like you
and I have had conversations more or
less around this before about the big
sort and about
um how people have become isolated and
and um uh not only geographically but
also in terms of the information they
gravitate towards that there is
basically an information outlet that
fits anyone's biases and and so what
this would mean for a poem ghost arm is
that all they knew were Republicans and
that when gosar actually went
door-to-door canvassing in Arizona to
get people to vote for Trump he would
say
um and his chief of staff told me about
this that you know I didn't meet any
Biden voters they just simply didn't
exist so it just simply made no sense
that this guy could come up with so many
votes and Flash Forward to
um a person will likely get to in a few
minutes um congresswoman Marjorie Taylor
dream I was having dinner with green a
month ago something like this and and
she said to me Robert I had said to her
that she was delusional about the 2020
election and
um and she said Robert you need to tell
me do you do you really believe that Joe
Biden got 81 million votes and I said
yeah yeah I mean that's what you got
that's that that's the organizing
principle of the of of your conspiracy
theory that because you can't imagine
this but in fact that played a big role
that um everyone she knew was a trump
supporter every uh every time especially
in 2020 that there was a crowd it was a
crowd for Donald Trump meanwhile Biden
and other people weren't campaigned
because of covet and and uh and it it
just was too stupefying an ocean for
them but then at the same time they
would say and but Trump got 74 million
votes he got more votes than he had the
first time he had to have won if his
vote totals went up but then we we're
not going to count I mean there's so so
much magical thinking that the same
system that seems to tabulate Trump's
votes doesn't count when it's counting
up Biden's votes it also it you know it
also fails to recognize the Trump you
know was a walking anomaly anyway in
um he came seemingly out of nowhere he
didn't win the popular vote but he still
he won a lot and in defiance of what
pollsters and pundits had imagined he
would do but that was because a lot of
people couldn't stand Hillary Clinton
and were willing to take a chance on
this disrupter yeah why that would you
know
um be so bizarre for them to recognize
the possibility that this same anomaly
would
um uh the independence and other swing
voters would ultimately find that
experiment to be a bad one would find it
to be distasteful it would move away
towards this very boring guy
um because they decided to go for
operation boring over operation you know
chaos and and
um the the anomaly worked for them
before and didn't work for the second
time doesn't ex doesn't erase the fact
that Trump was going to live and die you
know by his own anomalous
characteristics
um you know the second part then the
second lie is that the vote you know the
stolen election could be turned back
um and that leads us to January 6 and
you know I tend to call it a riot not an
Insurrection
um your uh your um kind of depiction of
it from inside and using different
sources really amazing and powerful and
I if uh people don't read the full book
read that because it's it's a really
Vivid account of you know of the
violence that was going on it's not not
yeah I mean it is a mob it's a mob
generally without weapons I mean they're
not shooting guns but there's a lot of
violence there and if you you know for
people who took seriously Ryan kits that
came out of black lives matter marches
or other kinds of things like you really
gotta you know you you gotta read this
part of the book and and take this
seriously
um but talk about where the idea came
that if somehow you know if Mike Pence
if uh you'd have said magic words or
that there was you know I mean because
did anybody really believe that you know
the Q Anon shaman was going to take over
the Capitol building and then the you
know Trump would somehow become
president like where did that theory
which is totally
fabulous you know or you know it's just
Fantastical that you could stop the
election of Joe Biden by doing something
with you know the Capitol building on
January 6th yeah I mean I think the the
to the extent that there is a unifying
theory in all of this Nick that the
unifying theory was in mega World Trump
is our champion he won
um uh victory was stolen from him he has
said come to D.C uh will be wild uh he
has done everything for us the only
things he he's asked for us is two
things first to vote and now to come to
Washington and fight like hell as he
would say on January the 6th and but I
think beyond that kind of consensus view
um there then get to be these these you
know when you disaggregate it there's
certainly people who showed up believing
and probably this this constitutes the
majority of people who just showed up
saying you know we want to support our
our president and and when I was there
and outside the capitol
um there were a lot of elements that
looked like the standard issue Mega
rally of which I've attended you know 15
or something like that there was another
group of people smaller but
um but still pretty large who believed
that um we need to do something Beyond
support we need to take our country back
and you know if if you believed as these
people did that democracy have been
thwarted have been weaponized against
them
um then you'd want to take action and
and I think most of those people came to
the Capitol not entirely sure what form
that would take but they were the ones
who constitute the real mob where the
third smallest subsection of all are the
violent actors who came you know with um
with the intent uh with with
Insurrection on the brain you know The
Oath Keepers of five percent Etc and uh
um but they couldn't have done it
without a mob and and you know those
were the people that I heard outside the
Capital once I got outside the building
and who were like this guy I heard
talking to his teenage son saying you
know son's free Freedom isn't free
sometimes you have to fight for it like
our forefathers did and I think now is
that time and it disappeared towards the
building I don't know what the hell
happened to them after that but it's but
as I was among this kind of pulsing mob
the the sense that I had was this is
absolutely out of control and
um and violence once there is an obvious
Target is the obvious conclusion of this
there turned out not to be an obvious
Target but had there been a Mike Pence
nearby had there been a Nancy Pelosi an
AOC or anything I mean God help them you
know and uh um it is a miracle in fact
you know and also a feat of of Capital
Security
um that there was not more Bloodshed
that day but then kind of the larger
legal theories and stuff like that
because you still hear I I'm you know
and I I mean a variety of not a very
variety a majority of Republicans did
not certify the elections right the
election results
did they I mean do those people think
you know by not signing on that they're
going to change the election result or
are they just kind of showing solidarity
with you know ill Supremo Donald Trump
or right well so absent you know absent
a thorough survey of all of them no such
survey exists I can only conjecture
based on the interviews that I've done
and that's that there were some who
truly believed funny business was afoot
and an absolute minimum there needed to
be a pause on the process so that we
could look into all of this stuff but I
would say a significant majority of
Republicans who voted
um to not to certify were ones who were
scared shitless frankly and who were
they scared of they were scared of their
constituents you know and and in real
time and I mentioned this in in my book
a freshman from Michigan named Peter
Meyer who would subsequently vote to
impeach and would subsequently be
successfully primary and bounced from
office
uh you know after one term was getting
these texts from donors and other
constituents saying hey don't wimp out
you know don't let a few broken windows
scare you from doing the right thing
here and and and that is when we ask the
question so why did you know all these
Republicans who seem to believe because
they experienced it firsthand
um that something terrible had taken
place that we as a democracy needed to
turn away from why did they turn away
from that notion the short answer is
they went home they went home and
listened to the constituents but in but
in even in those days leading up to
January the 6th
um you know their belief then and later
was
um uh and I heard this I can't count how
many times I heard this Nick from
Republicans who would say look you know
if I object
um uh then I'll get primary if I get
primary to the right of me I'll probably
lose if I lose that person who comes to
office will be Marjorie Taylor green
want another one of those or would you
Meyers yeah or in Myers district and he
replaced the ma Justin Amash who you
know the Republican who became an
independent voted to impeach Trump
became libertarian before not running
for reelection because he knew he was
going to be primaried that time by Peter
Meyer who then got primaried by a trump
candidate who yeah who was you know just
ridiculous and now that district is gone
right yeah so it's it's not even like
you get a trump person yeah it's it's
very um peculiar so then the final part
of this lie which and this is where
reality really takes kind of a Permanent
Vacation which is you have many of the
people who were implicated in January 6
and some you know some politicians
saying well you know what like January 6
was a bad thing but it wasn't Trump
supporters and Donald Trump didn't have
anything to do with it because it was
antifa where it was a false flag
operation by the FBI and the CIA and you
know the you know the PTA or something
something where is that coming from and
is does that have serious legs or is
that just the worst kind of people who
know they're they're guilty of something
uh even if it's just bad thinking you
know just want to try and make something
go away well I think that where it it
really comes from is
um I uh a right-wing media ecosystem
that knows that this stuff sells and has
become a cottage industry
um the whole January 6th political
persecution is itself you know a cottage
industry but you're referring Nick
specifically you know to this guy Alan
Hostetter who
um interesting story a guy who um had
been a police chief in a town in Orange
County California ultimately left became
a yoga instructor not very political at
all then the pandemic hits he becomes
radicalized by all of that and becomes a
big stop the steal proponent uh when
Trump does his you know come to
Washington will be wild hostile better
starts recruiting people to this task
and and uh and on social media saying
that violence is the likely outcome and
he's he's here for it you know time to
string people up time to execute the
treasonous people he um participates uh
in January the 6th he's um he is
ultimately uh indicted for that and is
still awaiting trial but in the interim
before he was actually indicted he
started a podcast in which he calls the
Insurrection The Fakes eruption and says
that this was all an FBI setup and um
possibly using violent actors like
antifa I mean here he is like just
elaborately contradicting everything
that he had stood for and espoused very
vocally and memorialized on social media
so um uh and and mean you know Flash
Forward later
um there are still some detainees in
January um in the DC jail waiting um
trial for January 6 related offenses and
and they are all now being cast as
political
um as politically persecuted and the
cottage industry supporting that
movement there are all these offshoot
groups as well as you know the Gateway
pundit types
um are yeah are now saying that take
your pick it was either
um antifa who did all this or it was the
FBI it's it the latter becomes a little
complicated because the FBI did have
informants you know that right inside
there but it but none of that's the the
likelier okay I'm sorry uh razor
explanation is that the FBI as the FBI's
want to do the left-hand didn't know
what the right hand was doing and um
because the evidence is fairly clear
that these guys were
um astonishingly flat-footed
um when January the 6th arose but uh but
but so
um but there's enough doubt and let's
face it almost every conspiracy theory
begins with some kernel of Truth or some
you know Quest question that does beg
answering
um but maybe not in such a you know
delusional way yeah and I mean in a lot
of ways I feel like we're we're living
in a Thomas pinchon novel like the
crying of lot 49 or something where you
know the FBI we know the FBI is a
terrible agency
um you know both the left and the right
and increasingly the mainstream can
agree on that FBI informants Were
Somehow involved in you know this the
plot to kidnap Gretchen Whitmer the the
governor of Michigan if you read
anything about the FBI history you know
they're terrible but we now have gotten
to a point where it's like you know
reality is so fungible to people's needs
and Desires in a given moment and I
think it's worth going back to that
larger point you know that uh that you
made at the beginning that one of the
reasons why Trump spoke to so many
people uh you know and he got 46 percent
of the popular vote in two presidential
elections that's a large chunk of people
is there are people who feel in
Desperate Straits they feel left behind
they feel
um you know unseen and um you know and
these kinds of stories bubble out when
there aren't good explanations or
nobody's reaching out let's talk about
you know if if your book has three
characters in Trump and I guess I you
know for all five of The Crying of lot
49 readers who might be out there if
Trump is kind of the Pierce and variety
of this uh of your book he's kind of the
looming shadowy Overlord who every it
makes everything happen but is not
really seen very much
um the the three main villains I would
argue are the characters in your book
are Paul Gosser who you've mentioned
Marjorie Taylor green and uh Kevin
McCarthy and I want to go through each
of them a little bit you mentioned gosar
he is a dentist who's a congressman from
Arizona and it was funny when you were
talking about him writing it I I you
know I knew the name and everything but
then when I looked him up I was
expecting somebody who is 95 years old
and you know had been a Bircher like
when the Birch Society started Etc he's
born in 1958 he's got you know he's got
his hair still has color in it and he
looks kind of normal but who is Paul
goser and why is he so Central to what
you're writing about in weapons of mass
delusion sure my interest in goats are
um precedes this book because he came in
with a tea party class in 2010 and um I
wrote a book about that class I
interviewed ghost arm in 2011 just
shortly after he took office and I found
him to be just breathtakingly
uninteresting and figured that here's a
guy we'll never hear from again he'll
probably you know be a one or two term
or maximum through flu redistricting
Etc
um he managed to last but he became
significant on a couple of levels to me
um first because uh as mentioned
um as unremarkable characters he was he
not only started the south of Steel uh
movement these are the rallies but he
also played this rather remarkable
moment in being the first congressman
who joined with a U.S senator to
formally object to the certification of
electoral votes of a particular state in
this case his own State Arizona which
led to this debate that then was
interrupted by the rioters the second
thing though is that um goats are is
um gosar is you mentioned a John Berger
and that's a really apt characterization
I think that in an earlier era that's
precisely what he would have been and he
would have been purged from the party as
a result but we see instead
um uh we'll get to Kevin McCarthy in a
minute but but leadership's utter
inability to punish someone like gozar
and in fact to defend gozar and and the
reason that um that McCarthy and others
defended go-star was not because they
liked them they didn't but because if
they did didn't defend him they would
incur the Wrath of the Maga movement
that essentially is the
um the the base of the Republican party
and the other thing interesting about
gosar is that for all of gosar's
weirdness he's also tried to be a real
legislator begging the question can you
say all this crazy [__] and then be
taken seriously
um uh you know when you're trying to get
bills passed and and the question
probably answers itself but I you know
the reporting that I do shows how people
who might have even been sympathetic to
some of his saner legislative
initiatives basically aren't going to
sign on and be a co-sponsor with a guy
who refuses to call Joe Biden President
Biden because he says he's illegitimate
and then calls it Mr Biden said are
there echoes in that just very briefly
in terms of refusing to recognize you
know Biden as president
um how is is there a line to be on
that's meaningful from when George W
Bush was selected as president by the
Supreme Court or by you know a few
hundred or a thousand voters in Florida
and there was a period when Democrats
refused to you know I mean they accepted
that it was president but they pushed on
that that he wasn't legitimate in the
way that Bill Clinton had been or that
Barack Obama would be
well certainly that's a line a
connective tissue that a lot of
Republicans would like to see us all
accept but I do think that scattered
protests disgruntlements and sword
losing is not the same thing as refusing
to recognize the legitimacy of a
president I mean being pissed off about
it saying that voters were suppressed
saying that your brother helped fix the
election in Florida you know that's um
is is one thing but being steadfast in
your insistence that this guy doesn't
belong in the White House and should
never be addressed by his title it's I
think something else yeah and um with
gosar you talk about how he um in a way
that is uh emblematic of something I
mean he was playing footsie with white
nationalists in a way that certainly
under George W bush
um uh you know that that would have been
grounds for being canned from the
Republican party or whatnot but talk
about
gosar's Connections to um you know kind
of white nationalists white supremacists
and how that is being tolerated in a way
that it wouldn't have been you know 20
years ago sure well I mean it starts
with the fact that
um whether anyone likes it or not and a
lot of Republicans don't like it a lot
of Republican you know responsible
Republicans
um white nationalists are not
insignificant part of the Republican
base that's just a fact I'm not saying
they're a majority but I'm saying that
that's you know um when you're trying to
amass a following amongst the base uh
there is the Temptation amongst those on
the right to court white nationalists or
at least wink you know wink and nudge at
them but the the gosar explanation for
speaking to the America First Pac led by
Nick Fuentes who was just an
Unapologetic white supremacist and and
very very anti-semitic among other you
know uh other things one can say about
Fuentes is that um this was a this was
um a group of young conservatives who
were in search of a leader basically
Margie Taylor green would say the same
thing to me too that um
these were uh a bunch of mainly you know
um white males uh who represented in a
sense
um uh the next generation of
conservatism and uh you you want to
cultivate those people you don't
necessarily want to uh humor some of
their baser Notions
um but you also don't want to condemn
them either so that was gosar's
rationale for doing this and and that
and a certain amount of ignorance that I
had no idea that Fuentes said these
things also he's gosource Chief of Staff
Tom van flying said to me like you know
he's a kid you know I did a lot of
stupid things when I was 25 years old
too but you know I I would hope that
those didn't include saying you know the
numbers don't add that about six million
Jews being you know executed in Nazi
Germany for example
um well let's talk about Marjorie Taylor
green
um because she I mean in a lot of ways
part of the argument of your book on on
some level is that Marjorie Taylor green
is not a fringe element of the
Republican party she represents quite
possibly the future of the Republican
Party
um who is Marjorie Taylor green and why
is she important in talking about when
the Republican Party lost its mind yeah
I mean three and a half years ago
um if you asked me those questions yeah
we we would wonder why we're having a
conversation about her at all she was
she and her husband uh owned a
successful family construction business
in um in the suburbs of Atlanta uh she
um uh was a conservative but not
politically active until 2018 when she
uh embraced the Q Anon conspiracy theory
and around that time became a right-wing
social media and influencer she started
going to Washington in 2019 to harassing
Democrats to increase her social media
following but also to implore
Republicans to pass uh to to block gun
safety legislation she couldn't get an
audience with any of these Republicans
she wanted to see it really pissed her
off and so here's this you know
millionaire conservative who's saying
hey I'm a taxpayer and these people
refuse to even grant me an audience
screw them I'm gonna run and she ran a
kind of would seemed like a flukeish
campaign but they were people took her
seriously because she had enough money
to self-fund but then through the luck
of um the draw a new District opened up
in Georgia when the Republican incumbent
decided to retire she moved in there
super conservative uh rural Northwestern
Georgia district and she won
convincingly but along the way all all
these Q Anon and other racially and many
other ways offensive posts came to light
and the Assumption Nick was when she
arrived in Washington that the
Republicans would kick her to the curb
she would be at the Star Wars bar where
Steve king of Iowa had once been and
should be out after a term or so instead
um uh the the most remarkable
um opposing trajectories occurred of two
uh female Republicans Liz Cheney the
most prominent uh Republican woman in
American politics
her career spiraled and she became
exiled from the party where Marjorie
Taylor green without changing any of her
views became as you're saying um you
know in a lot of ways Central to the
party in one of its most potent uh
Messengers what are the you know what
are two or three of the most insane
things that Marjorie Taylor green has
publicly said or believes
yeah so you're talking about
pre-congressional career or something
let's uh do one before and one or two
after yeah certainly I mean the the you
know the Q Anon stuff that included the
California wildfires were the result of
um uh a space laser shot from the skies
by uh a company owned by the wealthy
Jewish billionaire Rothschild family
um that one's pretty out there uh uh but
also just casual stuff like she would
say
um in in one of her posts that um you
know I don't know why black Americans
get so bent out of shape looking at
these Confederate statues or you know uh
or you know um statues of slaveholders I
mean if I'd I'd be proud to walk past
them because that would just show me how
far I've come I mean those kinds of
things but um but since she has come in
office uh her
um her claims that members of the
democratic members such as Jamie Raskin
um are our card carrying Communists that
they are and per saying as well that
um Republic Democrats want Republicans
dead and the killings have already begun
uh are themselves kind of straight out
of Q and on viewing the other side as
incorrigibly evil so uh that's a
thumbnail sketch and I mean you
mentioned that you had dinner with her
um you know is she when you're talking
to her and you're saying like hey you
know pass the butter is she like that or
is I mean how much of this is an act how
much of this is real maybe that doesn't
matter but I mean like what it what you
are to to share a cat yeah yeah two
overlapping questions you you posed
there so first as to you know
um sort of what she's like and then
we'll get to what she believes right
um as to what she's like
um
fairly normal you know at first blush if
you saw her and didn't know who she was
and just were conversing with her about
you know the weather or football or
something like that you'd find her to be
instantly recognizable as a standard
issue Southern
um uh conservative woman you know that's
uh uh of a certain affluence and and
um uh uh and and I must say in the many
times now that I spent with green she I
think has made a concerted effort to
impress upon me that she's normal that
her views are much more mainstream than
I think
um and and by the way I should say that
kind of works both ways because her I'm
the first member of the mainstream media
to spend time with her and certainly
um you may well be the last as well so
yeah actually you'd be so you would be
surprised I mean I think that that um I
mean we can get to the topic if you want
but uh she you know
um uh this is the kind of psychic
um you know bridge that she had to cross
the psychic Rubicon that that
um because her assumption was that we
were all evil you know that we're like
you know um we're but she failed to
detect any sulfur fumes I think when she
sat down and met with me I have a
Southern accent like her and and uh and
the the seeming normalcy you know kind
of plays both ways as to what she
believes
um the short answer to the question
how much of this does she believe is she
believes enough of it she also willfully
hyperbolizes she knows that that that's
what sells that's what gets you
attention and this is an attention
economy in which he's playing
um but at her core yes she does believe
the Democrats are if they're not
luciferian then they're basically
um they're destroying America she does
believe that and and uh and
um and I think you know when it comes to
this sort of existential situation that
she Embraces that that really you know
uh were in a war for the soul of America
um you know what's a little exaggeration
even a little outright lying uh when the
stakes are so great yeah and you know
this is probably beyond your uh
expertise but you know [__] it answer it
if you would like anyway I mean she's
interesting also because you mentioned Q
Anon and Q Anon among other things and
this is the idea that a deep State actor
is kind of speaking truth about all of
the horrors that are in the government
including the idea that many Democrats
and other world leaders are pedophiles
cannibals I mean like it's not simply
you know the bilderbergers run
everything in behind the scenes where
you know that Jews control the media or
anything like that I mean it's like that
plus a serious dose of you know kind of
where it comes from I don't know
pedophilia like fears are you know of
that Marjorie Taylor green is a former
Catholic who says the Catholic church is
a pedophile organization they're you
know there you we one can understand
that that comes out of you know the
churches the the priest scandals and
things like that but do you have a sense
of in Maga World
um it does seem that you know that
charge of pedophilia I mean which is you
know it's one thing to call your you
know to call Nancy Pelosi evil or you
know John podesta evil and I'm now
starting to wonder if this is maybe it
has something to do with them being
Catholic and Italian but not just that
they're evil but that they're pedophiles
and that they are tormenting and killing
and sexually abusing children and then
eating them what it I mean does that
make sense when you go through Maga
World why the turn to pedophilia yeah
yeah so I'll say by the way the grain I
think not only renounces Q Anon but is
genuinely ashamed that she took it as
far as she did but as to how she got
sucked into it to begin with
um it it it helped make Vivid
um for uh people like her who
um who didn't understand why Democrats
were so dismissive so heedless or
contentious
um uh uh that they were in fact evil you
know it's uh this that's a rather
bizarre you know and garish
manifestation of it but at least it
would explain why don't you care enough
about children
um the other thing too that Q Anon I
think
um was uh how it became so appealing to
so many people was the op was The Other
Side of The Ledger which is the heroism
of um not just their fearless leader
Donald Trump valiantly fighting this
pedophilia ring but how everyone who
supported Donald Trump was a patriot and
um and that this conferred on them a
real goodness
um a warrior status and uh you know and
an unqualified rightness uh and so to
cast the stakes in this comic book you
know this garish comic book fashion
um becomes if not more sensible at least
just irresistible for individuals who
want to feel of themselves that way and
and green said to me you know that she
she said look you'd you'd be surprised
how you know the people who are involved
in Q Anon like lots of affluent people
lots of successful people you know
Jeffrey Epstein and the whole you know
everybody at MIT in Harvard and you know
flying to his Island and all of it no
sure and and she you know when I asked
her why did you keep all that stuff up
you know your Social Media stuff the
crazy [__] from the past when you're
running for office why didn't you scrub
all us and she I remember I'll never
forget her response it was like I didn't
think it would hurt hurt me in fact I
kind of thought it would help me and
like that's that was a mind blower to me
but I have to say she was on to
something you know it's um like even
people who you know weren't into Q Anon
could still sympathize with the
fundamental views right the the opposite
side was evil and the their side was
locked in this you know kind of clash of
good versus evil and Kerry Lake you know
said that out loud this is about good
versus evil yeah and I I mean I guess
this stage you know one of the things
I'm trying to understand in a larger
context is someone who I just don't
viscerally understand Republicans Or
democrats uh you know and I I mean it's
not a it's a sign it's a lack in me but
on the on the liberal or Democratic side
you you see people use the idea that the
world is about to end uh you know like
what was it in 2018 we were told we have
you know 12 years to fix global warming
otherwise the world is over but you know
both sides in different ways and I'm not
making a uh you know a false
equivalencies here but like both sides
are you know it reminds me of growing up
in the 70s the world is about to end you
know whether through you know fire or
ice but and on the right it has taken
this form of like this is a cataclysm
and it's almost like you know Jesus is
coming back and you know have you do you
have the mark of the beast on you or not
like have did you stand up are you going
to be raptured or are you going to be
okay and it just you know where those
Stakes come from is kind of yeah I'm
still trying to figure that out in a way
well it's well so it's you know Nick you
and I you know for the sake of your
listeners
um met each other in 2014 when I was
doing a story about libertarianism and
you know when we and we talked a lot
about whether or not the libertarian
moment had arrived in 2014 short answer
no but but it made it to the cover that
question has the libertarian movement
finally arrived written by you that
story made it to the New York Times
magazine cover whatever but and I never
answered the question yeah no and and
you know the joke is that when a trend
hits the New York Times it's officially
over so I guess that's what happened to
them sort of like the Sports Illustrated
you know when you're a team Sports
Illustrated you're going to lose and
it's yeah and uh uh or get an ACL or
something but but yeah I um but but I
but in pondering so what happened to
whatever libertarian energy yeah there
was and that was was like a a healthy
distrust of government and a belief that
you know
that the less government the better
which has a spectrum of of Quasi you
know Anarchy to you know Rand Paul or
something
um that that something happened and the
Evangelical movement explained some of
this and I think conspiracy theorizing
is an overlap because when you and I
were talking Jade Helm was happening as
operation Jade Helm which was
um you know briefly uh a real military
operation a military exercise taking
place in a bunch of southern and western
states that through a series of
circumstances
um some people on the right began to
believe was a military a true military
operation being conducted by Obama to
seize people's guns to kill off
conservatives Etc and um and so there is
a fundamental difference between
thinking you know government's not good
and government is evil government is
luciferian and and something happened
um that whatever libertarian energy
there was was overtaken by this
eschatological notion of government and
of course yeah and and they overlap
because uh Ron Paul who's certainly you
know provided a ton of the libertarian
energy was a big Jade Helm guy and he
always is trafficked in conspiracy
theories that NAFTA was going to lead to
you know and it's confusing I mean
conspiracy theories rarely kind of are
are succinct or stable but NAFTA was
going to lead to a super highway from
Mexico to Canada which somehow would
lead to more immigrants coming here even
though you could drive from you know
Juarez to Ottawa or something in like 10
hours you know but
um so that you know the conspiracy
theory the religious fervor and the
belief of end times are all kind of
wrapped up and and I have to say you
know you'd be you know much more Adept
at figuring this than me but but the
reality that I've stumbled upon in my
reporting is that there that a lot of
these more
anti-democratic hard-right people in
places like Arizona and Georgia uh were
originally Ron Paul followers and you
know for example Marjorie Taylor greens
um uh top strategist this guy named
Isaiah Wartman
um was a Ron Paul person and uh in
Arizona people who and this is also true
in Wyoming too the people who came out
you know very against Liz Cheney
um the movement the anti-democratic
movement on the far right in Arizona and
Wyoming again these people were for
whatever reason they first found their
home in Ron Paul and they migrated over
to the anti-democratic climes of this
other movement so let's and I want to
talk about Kevin McCarthy because I
think he's the true problem in in many
ways because he's you know kind of the
adult in the room who is just like the
worst most absentee parent one could
imagine but see I just want to dilate on
this a little bit you know you have
Georgia which is interesting state where
it you know it was red for a long time
it is now you know it's a mix of red and
Bloom we're seeing something interesting
happen there Arizona you know on the
other side of the country also in the
southern region is kind of similar where
you know Arizona defined a kind of
Goldwater conservativism or you know
cold water to find Arizona as in such
place and now you're seeing in Arizona
um you know this same kind of thing
where it's it's not really purple but
there are hardcore blue people and
hardcore red people
um and they're clashing like they're not
mixing they're clashing
um what's going on in Arizona and this
you know well we can talk about the
midterms kind of along the way but
um it's you wrote a fantastic piece for
the New York Times about the Arizona GOP
and it was built this came out in August
it was about Cary Lake talk a little bit
about her and where she comes from and
if Marjorie Taylor green is one you know
future face of of the Republican party
is Carrie like another one even though
that she lost the governor race in
Arizona yeah so both green and Kerry
Lake were made possible by Donald Trump
I mean they very much followed the
template that he set of um sort of
performative right-wing politics Carrie
like is in many ways the apotheosis of
that as a person who'd been in media for
two decades and Dan used that much in a
way of a I'm just thinking about this
now of like a you know
um a some guy who you know was an
incorrigible drunk and beat his wife and
all that suddenly repenting and then
becoming a pastor and essentially using
his Bedrock of sin uh uh to uh claim
that he understands the Beast better
than anyone else Carrie lake is that
person now to briefly answer your
question about Lake's future I still
think she has one and I think people who
I mean for someone who as someone who
saw her at close range
um she's on a certain level mesmerizing
just on a performative level I mean no
one kind of hits the mark quite like she
does
um but Arizona
um you're right Nick is I mean it's a it
is it's a subject of Fascination to me
because it's a it's uh now it's lost
um the governorship to the Democratic
party both of its senators are uh are
democratic the legislature is barely in
control of the Republicans by literally
like a couple of legislators and so with
those Trends in mind you'd think that
the Republican party there would do well
to take stock of them and uh and
Endeavor to um you know expand the tent
as it were they've done the opposite
they've doubled down on right-wing
extremism and as you mentioned the the
very gold water and then later John
McCain have been viewed as kind of the
faces of the Republican party it's
always been a little more complicated
than that I mean it's uh uh you know
goldwater's wife was a co-founder of one
of the chapters of planned paren good
um but there were a lot of people on the
right who didn't cut into that they just
didn't have a kind of coherent movement
going on they couldn't stand
um McCain for saying for referring to uh
members of you know the right-wing
religious movement those agents of
intolerance they couldn't stand his
immigration policies uh but they also
couldn't quite get their power together
now they've managed to do so and we'll
see how long it lasts there but it's but
I but that was the other reason why I
was interested in ghosts are in green
because I happened to be you know faces
on two of these states that were
quasi-determinative in 2020
um and states were clearly the trends
are moving at least somewhat away from
the Republican party but you wouldn't
know what to see
um uh to see the Republican in Arizona
it's amazing too because you have a very
successful and popular two-term Governor
Doug Ducey who you know is not a Liber
libertarian but he's he's a kind of
Centrist Republican for sure and he
could have won that Senate race that
Blake Masters lost he could have won by
double digits without breaking a sweat
but he couldn't be the candidate because
Donald Trump hated him because Doug
Ducey like an adult human being refused
to say things that were obviously false
about the election and things like that
and so that gets to you know in a way I
mean Kevin McCarthy who is likely to
become the next Speaker of the House who
is Kevin McCarthy and why does he matter
so much in weapons of mass delusion sure
Kevin McCarthy was elected to office in
2006 to Congress from Bakersfield
California previous to that he had been
the staff aide to
um Bill Thomas who had held that seat
for a very long time McCarthy utterly
non-ideological
um not much of a belief system at all
very ambitious uh fellow seeing with him
ambition as I say in the book so he
doesn't have time for ideology or policy
because yeah it's like I'm taking over
by ambition
right but also you know has a head
by you know some data Geeks have a head
for baseball statistics as a head for
Precinct by Precinct politics uh and
um uh and had from his early 20s been
infatuated with Donald Trump and uh so
um he has risen in the ranks he was I
covered him during the the tea party
period when he was the majority whip in
the house and he was one of the
so-called Young Guns right yeah that's
right younger Paul Ryan Eric Cantor
that's right yeah
okay yeah yeah yeah they're all gone and
McCarthy's been the Survivor and this
has been his moment in fact he said to a
confidante you know recognizing the how
the historical
um Trends tend to favor the party out of
power in
um the party with power in their first
term of uh president's first time of
office you know he said to a confident
you know the upside the bind winning is
now I have a pretty good shot of being
speaker and yeah that appears to be be
the case though with a absolute razor
thin majority why is he Salient not just
because of that but also because of um
uh as you say he would seem to be the
face of the adult in the room Republican
and yet really is the face of uh of the
enabling of the Maga movement because he
he made the determination after January
the 6th that
um as much as he was literally
frightened for his life actually said to
Trump on the phone they are [__]
trying to kill me as I report in my book
that that
um that the Republicans couldn't exist
the House Republicans could not Prosper
without
um the blessings of trump because of his
his hold over uh the base and so he very
famously went to Mar-A-Lago and and been
to the knee
um and in other ways has coddled
Marjorie Taylor green Paul gosar uh and
uh uh and really behaved himself
um like if not a right-wing extremist
himself one who was far more approving
of them than of say Liz Cheney everybody
else's idea of a you know a solid
conservative who nonetheless
um uh was outraged by Trump's conduct
and and
um how he had enabled uh what happened
on January the 6th uh so McCarthy
basically when I described you know
margin Taylor green going up Liz Cheney
going down yeah there was McCarthy very
much
um kind of like the Matador with the
case you know letting each of them
happen
um what does it say that you know let's
assume he becomes Speaker of the House
in the 21st century the least
objectionable Republican speaker might
be a convicted child molester Dennis
hastert you know that or or most
effective I mean it's it's bizarre and
insane and obviously it's weird because
I'm not a fan of Nancy Pelosi but she is
an effective speaker of the house like
obviously that job is one of the worst
jobs to have and she's able to do it in
a way you know that traditionally there
have been a couple of others like that
but that's yeah yeah and of course we'll
see what happens once she vacates
leadership and I have no you know Intel
as to when that will occur but whether
um the more
um extreme elements in the Democratic
party uh begin to create the kind of
Havoc that the Marjorie Taylor greens
and Paul gosars and Matt Gates have done
uh in the Republican party but it
certainly is the case as you're
indicating that she has amp those down
pillows he has whatever one thinks of
her belief system she has wielded power
um very formidably right and she has
kept uh you know kind of AOC in her
Posse and some of the more Progressive
Democrats in in a pen I mean she's
corralled them in a way uh and there
were a lot of stories when they first
started Rising about the way that she
kind of backhanded them but she's a
short-term or whether it's because they
go into the minority or you know there
are a lot of reports she'll be leaving
uh to become Ambassador the Vatican or
whatever you know I mean she's 80 uh you
know these people you know I realize if
you're in the Bay Area you have blood
boys and stuff like that so you know but
eventually they give up right
um
do you do you uh let's talk a little bit
about how the midterms affect what
you're talking about in the book because
you know by all accounts the Republicans
should have won between 30 and 60 seats
in the house they should have picked up
five or ten seats in the Senate that
didn't happen but the you know the house
is going to be Republican the Senate is
almost certainly going to be Democrat
but it's going to be very tight
um how does this and Trump has just as
you know just a few hours before we talk
whenever this goes out Trump announced
that he's running for president in 2024.
his guys lost in a pretty significant
way across the board I mean there were
the secretaries of States who denied the
2020 election they all lost with one
exception the guy in Wyoming
um his preferred candidates is Senate
candidate somebody like Blake Masters uh
somebody like Herschel Walker somebody
like Mamet Oz these are people who lost
or you know Walker may still eat out of
Victory but they it's clear his chosen
people people the bigger the race the
bigger the bomb that they were
um you know JD Vance and Ohio won and
you know after spectacularly kissing you
know Trump's ass and and being
humiliated by him at public rallies as a
former critic now Etc but it seems that
Trump you know he may
you know in terms of the midterm
elections like he can't be coming out of
this uh more powerful and does that
change the calculus of what you're
writing about in the book
the short answer is no so that's um I
mean uh as my book makes clear
um Trump and trumpism have never been
popular and and never popular across the
board to a general electorate and given
the opportunity to express that distaste
for Trump and trumpism the general
electorate will do so it has done so
time and again it did so yet again yeah
we know we know definitively you know
and again I'm an election believer I
guess but that he can get about 46 of
the popular votes that's what he did in
two you know uh you know consecutive
elections like he's not going to get 54
the next time out that's right yeah so
so you know the the question with Trump
and trumpism has always been
um uh what effect they have on the
Republican party there is there is an
additional question
um perhaps just as significant which is
that um As Long As Trump and trumpism
have a hold on the Republican party what
kind of damage can they do to the
country even in the face of defeat right
and and so January the sixth being one
you know expression of that one
manifestation but you know and the other
um sort of more lingering one is the
tens of millions of people who believe
these delusions who believe these lies
um not just relating to
um stolen elections not just relating to
January the sixth but also relating to
uh covet relating to
um uh the great replacement Theory you
know and what's happening on the border
or what's not happening uh and um but
you know I I do think speaking directly
to you know what the midterms tell us
about Trump
look I mean I've um uh people are now
you know saying to santis is you know
the um has got the inside track and that
may well be so but I also well remember
and you do too that
um when you and I were talking about
Rand Paul in the context of
libertarianism and presidential politics
a lot of other people were talking about
Scott Walker as the great hope of the
Republican party because he also uh the
um conservatives loved him for how he
stood up to the Press how he stood up to
the unions and busted them uh did
everything a conservative you'd want to
conservative to do except campaign well
and he was a dud we really have no sense
whatsoever how DeSantis will do even as
a standalone proposition but it's an
altogether different thing to see
DeSantis against the human wrecking ball
that is Donald Trump right Donald Trump
cleared out what I mean it was amazing
yeah he had what like 16 or 17. yeah
yeah you know plausible Republicans so
we're not it wasn't a bunch of clowns on
the show
Ted Cruz Etc yeah and people forget that
they think that you know today it's it's
thought that they all must have been a
bunch of weak sisters no we're not I
mean those were that that was really a
dream slate of you know yeah
um yeah and I I think of DeSantis I mean
it remains to be seen and I'm not sure
actually how much I care about this but
he also reminds me of Chris Christie who
also was very effective in New Jersey
stood up to unions publicly played well
in New York and New Jersey and you know
I'm from that area and I I was a
columnist for time at the time and I
wrote about how Christy plays great in
that area but there's no way like once
you cross the Delaware River West he's
people are going to be like who is this
fat [__] loudmouth I don't know if I
mean it was like after the after Trump's
announcement speech I mean so much Focus
perhaps unsurprisingly in the media
where all the people in the room were
bored oh it was the same thing over and
over they're missing the point which is
the point being that for the Mega
constituents the same old song is
exactly what they want to hear it's the
greatest thing I don't want to hear the
slightest dph Drive
um so let me so that will play out what
is the effect of trump or Maga you know
for as a shorthand for a broader
movement what is the effect of that on
the Democratic party because you know
and it's weird because Biden uh the The
Washington Post and I think they were
accurate about this when they they said
that Joe Biden's presidential platform
was the most liberal a Democrat had ever
run on he was talking about 11 trillion
dollars in new spending he seemed normal
because he was running against Trump but
he's not just a kind of big government
Democrat but he and he got a lot of what
he wanted he is not popular he is also
being you know attacked from the left in
the Democratic party I mean you know the
the younger generation of Democrats they
hate Maga but they're also sick of
um you know of of Joe Biden and of Nancy
Pelosi and of You Know The Eccentric
Senate stuff you know they like Bernie
Sanders do you think how does that play
out particularly after the midterms
through the Democrats you know is there
going to be do you think there'll be an
Insurgency on the Progressive side of
Democrats to say this is our moment
um because this isn't cutting it what
we're seeing going on now yeah I mean I
um interesting to to hear you ask that
question because I've talked to some
Progressive leaders who do believe that
they're making inroads right now with
the Biden Administration and I mean in a
way they are they're getting a lot of
spending and a lot of the things that
they want but not quite belief is the
the you know this will benefit the
public but even if the public doesn't
come to see it their aversion to Trump
is so deep and abiding that that will
overcome whatever deficiencies they may
see I mean meanwhile you know it's it's
not entirely clear that Biden will run
again I mean I I did happen to notice
the day after the midterm from Biden
kind of did his Victory lap of a speech
that when asked he said on at least two
occasions my intention is to run which
is very different from just saying
declaratively I'm running you know mofo
and and uh and that kind of language you
know you and I have heard in Washington
forever and it's it's wiggle room for a
reason and leads me to believe that
maybe over the holidays he and his
family will discuss all this I mean he's
on top of whatever else you know we've
been talking about regarding Biden he's
quite old and and um yeah so is Nancy
Pelosi Pelosi seems to be quite you know
vigorous and quite effective Mitch
McConnell also ancient by political say
I mean I keep thinking back to those
pictures of you know Soviet uh you know
apparatchex in the in the 70s and 80s
and you're like God they were so old and
it's like you know president was in his
50s and it's like we have people 30
years older than him running the country
um if I may also um you know uh what do
you think that this rhetoric of stolen
elections and rigged systems Etc and
again I think back to 2016 Hillary was
saying a version of it Bernie Sanders
was Trump was and again not to make them
all equivalent but there's a palpable
sense throughout much of America and
this this undergirded empowered the
black lives matter movement right that
you know like it doesn't matter if if
you're black and American you work hard
and you play by the rules you're still
going to be killed by cops you're not
going to get ahead there's racism you
know and then there's a a kind of
de-industrialized Midwestern version of
that there's a Latino version of there's
you know uh as we speak there's a
Supreme Court case about Asians Asian
Americans being kept out of Harvard and
and University of North Carolina and
Elite institutions there's a real
palpable sense that the system is broken
or the systems are broken and Hillary
Clinton who I guess doesn't really have
many divisions anymore but she in a
recent fundraising appeal for a group
called indivisible talked about how you
know in the pitch he says extreme
right-wing conservatives have a plan to
disallow the you know to win the 2024
election to steal the election and we
need to crush the coup that's the actual
language for this fundraising appeal do
you think that kind of election
denialism is going to go kind of
mainstream or ubiquitous or and more and
more disintegration of belief or
cynicism towards any kind of major
institution major undertaking over the
next few years
yeah I mean I will say you know I first
I think that you know crush the coup is
is at minimum really really ill-advised
you know that uh rhetorically
um but but I I do recognize because as a
reporter as a citizen who follows the
news you can hear Republican state
legislators say out loud that their
intention is in fact to make it more
difficult for
um certain constituencies to vote and
some of them have said explicitly
because of our efforts to do these kinds
of things we Republicans are going to
win more and so their they themselves
are casting it as a partisan effort
regardless of whether you know this is
um a you know systematized
um carefully orchestrated thing here and
there it's certainly the truth I mean
you know what you're referring to Nick
is is a is a larger distrust you know
the distrust of Institutions goes back
to Vietnam obviously you know and then
Watergate but it has gotten to a point
now where the view is feels not just
that institutions are hoary and and have
their own kind of inertia but that they
act at minimum
um are dismissive of of ordinary
Americans and at maximum uh are
contemptuous of and and deceptive
towards and they're killing them and
eating them I mean in some cases I mean
literally yeah right right exactly yeah
and it's and I I don't know where and
how that ends I mean it's interesting
you know to referring to Marjory Taylor
green to see her now and she has
expressed to me that she actually wishes
to be taken more seriously and to govern
seriously to she's willing to like let
her actions speak for themselves
um and there she was uh you know uh
standing with Kevin McCarthy the other
day
um saying how you know
um Republicans need to get in line and
back him for speaker something I
wouldn't have expected her to do before
but when the rubber meets the road the
question will be
um you know are you gonna like try to
govern responsibly while at the same
time
um having endless investigations of your
political enemies and um so uh uh so
we'll you know we'll see if you know
someone like green
um tries to reform the institutions from
within or continually cast them as demon
figures as a kind of final uh point to
this conversation you're a Texas guy and
you open the book with um I think a
particularly uh important and moving but
you know important
um uh discussion of your father who died
I guess during covet right yeah he died
in November 2019 just before covet and
yeah
but and it was a lifelong Republican and
a kind of Texas way which I take to be
um that you know is is a kind of uh you
know smaller government uh you know a
small government kind of Live and Let
Live kind of Republican right uh an
older style
um who was contemptuous of trump but you
know is there do you think like the the
kind of politics his politics that
emerge which seem to be you know broadly
speaking you know kind of socially
tolerant fiscally responsible
um I don't know that that actually adds
up to being libertarian in any
meaningful way and I don't really care
about that but that idea
um where you know you you have a
government that you don't want to do
everything but you wanted to do certain
things and you believe that it can do
those and you'll support that and you
also think that people in businesses
should mostly be left to their own
devices
um you know that immigration is good
that free trade rate is good that
movement is good and you know when
people need to change and grow is there
um is there a path forward for that kind
of politics given what we're seeing
emerging kind of on an extreme right
where you know National conservatives
are you know somebody like a blank
Masters said libertarianism doesn't work
and that the government really needs to
be controlling things Ron DeSantis says
we need to use the power of the state to
go after our enemies the way the left
does uh people on the Progressive caucus
are talking about taking over
nationalizing social media and platforms
like that is you know is the the country
that your father lived in is that gone
forever or is that a viable kind of
synthesis of what comes out of these
moments of Madness of the past half
dozen years or so I do think that
um maybe even the majority of Republican
office holders embrace the views that my
dad did which yeah I think distill them
well distill themselves down to
um you know healthy distrust of
government less government lower taxes
emphasis on personal responsibility
um and um uh and would love to see that
the Beast that they have at least
implicitly if not explicitly fed for
years will uh will eat itself the the
the one you know important ingredient to
my father that I mentioned in the
preface of my book is that
um he uh personal responsibility to him
meant um never making excuses never
um uh being a professional victim and
certainly never
um demonizing the other side after all
that would have made it very difficult
for him to stay happily married like he
was
um for 64 years to my mother who was a
Democrat and who cheerfully you know
canceled his vote out every election
cycle and uh and you know Ron DeSantis
becomes more of my father's kind of
Republican but only
um if he
divest himself of this rhetoric that
casts
um uh wokism as you know the Liberals as
possessed by woke ISM possessed by
radical socialist ideas and basically
people who must be punished who must be
ground to dust and and uh you know my
dad was always of the view and
Republicans were really for a very long
time until Trump showed them a different
way of
um of trying to persuade people that
that their way was a better way now I'm
not in you know I'm not in any way
idealizing
um conservatism back in my father's day
since it was a table around which sat
almost exclusively you know white men
and uh and and you've written more than
one book on on the bushes particularly
George W bush as in curious and in in
profound ways of failed presidents I
mean you're not a republican apologist
by anything no no and it's and
um uh and and I think that you know they
it was the
um you know the group think
um in the confirmation bias uh uh in the
very very limited world view that George
W bush had that was a big contributor to
the disaster that was the Iraq War and
my father loved George W bush but came
over the years to believe that he had
been LED astray by his own biases and
his own in curiosity and I think that
informed in turn how my father you know
came to seek alternative points of view
too so I don't I I'm by Nature not a
very prescriptive person and and uh um
and so I don't know how one comes back
to that but do I think that you know the
um that the opportunity is there and
that the numbers are there amongst
Republicans yes my greater concern is
that when you have so many millions of
people who um are possessed by delusions
and then and that underpinning those
delusions is the belief that the other
side is is satanic
um then I don't know how you come back
to well you know look we still need to
work across the aisles with those people
we disagree with I mean it's you you
don't work across the aisle with the
margin Taylor Greener is actually quite
honest when she was asked as as a
candidate uh running for uh Congress if
she would ever walk across the aisle and
and she basically said no she said no
that's um because uh we just have to
defeat them we can't persuade them uh
they're there for things we abhor and um
that was a kind of zero-sum language
that just didn't exist during my
father's era of Republican politics do
you think though then maybe it is a
little bit heartening and for God's sake
nobody wants to you know pin the hopes
of the Republic on Marjory Taylor green
but the fact that she seems to be more
accommodating
um particularly if she becomes part of
of a majority that is very small and
actually to do anything will have to
actually work with other people I have a
wait and see attitude about green
because it depends on whether I mean
it's um to to try to govern a certain
way but still to be tweeting and and on
right-wing media saying these kinds of
things about you know the killings have
already begun you know I don't care if
she wants to you know raise the debt
ceiling I mean I do care but if she's
saying that kind of stuff too then she's
feeding delusions and feeding this
apocalyptic you know fever uh so
um I understand that one reason she does
that is to get attention and to get
attention means to get online donations
and to get online donations means to
become a national figure but at a
certain point she has a choice to make
because those two come in conflict and
Paul gosar is one case and point of how
they come in conflict
all right we're going to leave it there
the book is Weapons of Mass delusion
when the Republican Party lost its mind
the author is Robert Draper Robert
thanks so much for talking it was really
a pleasure thanks for having me on Nick
[Music]